إنه أكثر ما تشتهر به الذئاب ، لكن
هذا جعل الباحثين يصرخون
بسعادة
في كلمات
الأستاذ جو بومب بجامعة مينيسوتا ، إنه
مثل الفوز في يانصيب العواء الذي
يضعه مشروع فويجرز وولفز مئات
من كاميرات المسار في حديقة فويياجور الوطنية
في شمال مينيسوتا
و  تحدث عن المكان المناسب في
الوقت المناسب ،
ولم يكتف الذئب رقم 94 بالعواء بمجرد
تبديل الاتجاهات وعواء مرتين
[موسيقى]
هناك أسطورة عن الذئاب وهذا
ما تعوي الذئاب عند القمر
[تصفيق] في
الواقع يقول الخبراء إنهم كيف
يتواصلون مع  يخبرون بعضهم البعض
بمكان وجودهم
أو أن أعضاء الحزم الأخرى
يحبونها عندما ينشر مشروع voyagers wolf
صورًا من كاميرات دربه
من الجراء الخارجين من عرين الذئب أو الأم
تحمل الطعام إلى المنزل للأطفال
الذين طلبوا من المشاهدين ذلك  خمن ما هو
للعشاء ، ماذا كان لديك
تخمين جيد كان الجميع يقول سمور لذلك
أنا ذاهب مع سمور ، يبدو أنك تصحح
كل ذلك  العواء يلقي بظلاله
على الذئب يتخبط لأسفل شاهد تلك
العيون المخيفة بينما تتدلى الجفون ويغفو الذئب ،
فإن دعوة البرية هي أيضًا نداء
الجني
النائم في نيويورك
[موسيقى]